if I say who are the biggest podcasters
today not political at all okay you got
Rogan you got you know impulsive you got
you know whoever you know call her that
you know all these things that you see
not necessarily political you can say
these are the most influential ones
right within the conservative side who
would you say are the top five most
influential media companies today
yeah you name them I mean if people
consider them you know conservative you
have Fox on there you'd have daily wire
on there um you know you probably have
like a red State Town Hall Salem it's a
big one okay yeah very familiar with
them uh I I don't know I mean arlas with
Salem right krlies with Salem kklas they
do they have like red State Town Hall a
lot of radio stations so they're really
big uh you know why I'm asking a
question I'm asking a question because I
don't know if there's enough of them
that's what I'm asking
[Music]